Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Drei Spieltage sind jetzt vergangen. Seit dem letzten Zweitliga-Kurzpass höchste Zeit wieder draufzuschauen. Hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 185. Und zudem begrüße ich euch ganz herzlich. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Edgenetzer auf Twitter. Und wie es inzwischen, ja ich würde sagen, jetzt schon eine Tradition ist, habe ich wieder zwei Gäste hier. Ich begrüße, es ist so schön, diese Stimmen wieder zu hören. Es sind so, also die Leute, die schon länger beim Rasenfunk mit dabei sind, die werden beide Gäste wiedererkennen. Zum einen Matthias Kneifl. Ihr kennt ihn vom Hoch- und Weitpodcast. Ihr kennt ihn als Autor des Kick-Schuh-Blogs und auch als Autor unter anderem des Buches 111 Gründe, den SV Darmstadt 98 zu lieben. Und vielleicht habt ihr jetzt auch erraten, was einer der Schwerpunktvereine dieser Folge sein wird. Hallo Matthias. Ja, es ist sehr schön, dich mal wieder mit dabei zu haben. Ich hab jetzt gar nicht mehr nachgeguckt, wann du das letzte Mal hier warst.
Ja, also ich denke, Dieter Hegging ist schon die eine Komponente, der vielleicht auch so ein bisschen Kontinuität auf der Position wieder reinbringt, weil man doch relativ viel Wechsel in den letzten Jahren hatte, mit erst von Bornemann auf Palikutia und dann von nach nur im knappen Jahr von Palikutia dann auf Hegging, also dass da ein bisschen Ruhe auf der Position reinkommt, weil ein Vorstand ja eigentlich keine Position sein sollte, wo so wahnsinnig viel Rotation oder Wechsel drin ist. Das andere ist aber durchaus auch der Vorstandspartner mit Nils Rosso, der eben ganz anderen Ansatz nochmal wählt, der eben sagt, wir müssen den Verein auch in der Stadt etablieren. Der ist in den Jahren vorher in der Stadt halt nicht so wahrgenommen worden. Es ist auch krass, wenn man mit potenziellen Sponsoren spricht, wie viel in der Zeit, gerade in der Spätphase von Martin Bader noch und dann auch in der frühen Phase von Michael Mieske, der dann ein bisschen da dagegen gearbeitet hat, wie viel Sponsoren verprellt worden sind einfach durch das Auftreten. Und man versucht das jetzt wieder durch so zivilgesellschaftliche Aktionen auch, also ganz viel. Ich bin ja im echten Leben jenseits des Journalisten auch noch Lehrer und nehme jedes Jahr auch mit meinen Klassen an dem Projekt gegen Antisemitismus vom FCN teil, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Teil der CSR-Maßnahmen des FCNs. Und da gibt es eben noch ganz viel andere, also es gibt eine Aktion, die nennt sich Spielräume. Da werden dann irgendwie Spielplätze wieder neu aufgebaut, das wird aufgeräumt. Der Raum von der Nürnberger Tafel ist renoviert worden mit Hilfe des FCN. Also man versucht so den Ansatz des Etablierens des Vereins in der Zivilgesellschaft auch noch mal, und ich glaube, das ist fast genauso wichtig, weil halt einfach die Stadt wieder mitgenommen werden will und auch muss, um ein bisschen davon wegzukommen, von dem, was gerade, da muss man in die Baderzeit zurückgehen, vor allem, was da viel kaputt gemacht worden ist, auch, dass man sich eben so ein bisschen da in der Hinsicht abgeschottet hat. Und das, finde ich, funktioniert ziemlich gut. Also man begegnet so dem FCN an ganz vielen Stellen im normalen Leben jetzt auch wieder. Also ich musste jetzt gerade einen Zettel von meiner Tochter unterschreiben, dass, wenn der FCN in der ersten Klasse zu Besuch kommt, dass sie fotografiert werden darf und auf die Homepage oder auf den Facebook auftritt, dass das Foto dann darf. Also man merkt es dann auch an so Kleinigkeiten, dass der FCN halt wieder versucht, mehr reinzukommen. Und das ist, denke ich, fast genauso wichtig wie der sportliche Teil, weil dann eben auch so der Verein an sich wieder mehr ins Bewusstsein der Leute kommt.
Ja, spannender Punkt. Der Klub war ja einer der ersten Vereine in der 2. Liga. Definitiv, ich glaube aber auch liegarbeit im deutschen Profifußball, der eben eine eigene CSR-Abteilung eingerichtet hat. Also Corporate Social Responsibility ist der Name zur Abkürzung. Das heißt, es geht eben einfach um die gesellschaftliche Verantwortung, die man als Verein hat. Das kann auch viel PR sein, aber du hast jetzt einige Aktionen genannt und da waren jetzt gar nicht alle Dinge mit dabei. Also man hat sich ja auch den ökologischen Schutz des Klimas auf die Fahnen geschrieben. Will jetzt hier nicht jede kleine Aktion hier nennen, aber das ist schon wirklich interessant, dass der Club da weiter ist als ganz viele andere Fußballvereine und meinem Blick von außen nach. Und das scheint es jetzt zu bestätigen, eben nicht nur, um sich selbst ein gutes Image zu geben, sondern eben, um viele Dinge im Kleinen zu bewegen, weil das eben auch positiv am Club haften bleibt und das macht was mit der Verwurzelung in der Region. Spannender Ansatz. Dann lasst uns noch über zwei weitere Vereine sprechen bei Regensburg. Da hat sich vom spielerischen her jetzt nicht so viel verändert. Deswegen wollen wir mal noch auf Schalke 04 und auf den FC St. Pauli gucken. Platz 3 und Platz 1 in der aktuellen Tabelle. Matthias, lass mal mit Schalke beginnen. Die kommen so langsam richtig ins Laufen. So macht es zumindest den Eindruck, haben sich immer mehr jetzt in diese zweite Liga reingebissen und liegen jetzt eben auf diesem dritten Tabellenplatz mit 22 Punkten. Konnten jetzt auch wieder gewinnen. Das war jetzt dann schon der vierte Sieg in Folge in der Liga. Was funktioniert denn gerade bei Schalke jenseits von Terode, was vorher noch nicht funktioniert hat?
Vielleicht war es ja mit der Torwartwechsel, dass Fermann raus rotierte und dafür Freisel rein. Freisel kennen wir noch aus Sandhäusner Zeiten. Ich habe den damals schon als sehr selbstbewussten und ehrgeizigen Vertreter seiner Zunft gemeint kennengelernt zu haben. Er ist schon einer, der, glaube ich, die Chance, die er jetzt bekommen hat, nur zu willig ergreift und er auch dann ein paar mal seine Flugkünste unter Beweis gestellt hat. Aber an und für sich, glaube ich, Schalke hatte lange genug Zeit, sich auf die zweite Liga vorzubereiten. Hat sich auch, finde ich, mit wichtigen Personalien da verstärkt und scheint jetzt im Moment einfach auch so gefestigt zu sein. Also das wurde nach dem Spiel gegen Dresden ja auch der Teamgedanke immer wieder heraufbeschworen und sie haben sich als Einheit dargestellt oder vorgestellt und da, glaube ich, mit den Ergebnissen wächst so ein gewisses Selbstverständnis heran. Und mich hat jetzt am Samstag eher Dresden überrascht in der Herangehensweise und in der Art, wie sie gespielt haben, zwar ohne jeglichen Ertrag, aber Schalke hat dann auch gewusst, okay, wir kriegen vielleicht noch mal eine Chance, dann machen wir einen Deckel drauf und so war es dann tatsächlich. Und gerade der Ovejan ist ja schon sehr auffällig, finde ich. Das war vielleicht ein nicht minder wichtiger Neuzugang. Also hat, glaube ich, bis langende im Liga-Vergleich die meisten, lass mich mal kurz gucken, bevor ich da Quatsch erzähle, die meisten Schlüsselpässe, die meisten Flanken und hat jetzt auch schon sechs Vorlagen mit den zwei vom Wochenende. Also der scheint ja auch die Situation mit Haut und Haaren anzunehmen in dem Club. Also lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, ich glaube, sie haben sich an den richtigen Stellen verstärkt. Wie gut an der 2. Anzug passt, mussten sie bislang noch nicht sonderlich austesten. Also mal gucken, wenn da Säulen wegbrechen. Latza war es jetzt zugegebenermaßen, wurde aber durch Pahlzon auch gut aufgefangen. Mal gucken, wenn sie richtig gefordert werden, ob da noch mal was ins Wangen gerät. Aber für den Moment wirkt es sehr in sich überzeugt, sehr ehrgeizig und im Vergleich zu Bremen, die wir vorhin besprochen hatten, erstmal auf dem richtigen Weg.
Auch auswärts sehr stabil. Der FC Schalke 04 in der Auswartstabelle Rang 2 mit vier Siegen und nur einer Niederlage bei 8 zu 4 Toren. Zuhause gab es ein bisschen mehr, auch für den Gegner zu holen. Das wurde ja auch gerade am Anfang der Saison. Hat man das ja auch medial gut mitbekommen, wie da die Schalke auch so manchen Punkt verloren haben zuhause. Flo, das scheint mir dann eine Mannschaft zu sein, wo wir, wenn wir gerade über Nürnberg gesprochen haben, mit sieben Gegentreffern. Schalke hat mit elf jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig mehr kassiert. Die sind einfach sehr stabil und wenn du vorne ja nicht nur ein Terrode hast, sondern Böte ist jetzt auch schon bei vier Treffern. Wenn du vorne eben dann in der Regel immer triffst, dann ist das ja auch schon eine gute Basis für eine sehr gute Zweitligasaison.
Ja, also ich denke die angesprochenen Punkte sind schon auch noch sind sind wirklich wichtig, also dass man halt einfach, man hatte auf Schalke ja eigentlich wirklich genug Zeit sich vorzubereiten auf die zweite Liga. Es war ja dann doch relativ früh klar, dass man absteigt und ich denke, das ist auch so der Unterschied zu Bremen. Also man hat halt da einfach schon an einem Kader in gewisser Weise bauen können, der dann Zweitliga relevant und tauglich ist. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ovej Harn heißt er. Ich weiß es nicht. Es ist wirklich ein absoluter Schlüsseltransfer, sehe ich genauso. Martin Freisel ist mir auch schon sehr oft in Sandhausen aufgefallen. Also das sind halt auch genauso so Geschichten, die mit rein spielen und dann eben zusätzlich auch noch. Ich denke, man hat am Anfang einfach gebraucht, weil naja, wenn man so viele Neuzugänge hat, dann müssen die halt auch erst zusammenfinden. Und jetzt läuft es. Und dann hat man eben doch einen Trainer, der die, aber da kann, muss ich gar nicht so viel sagen, da gibt es andere hier, die da mehr dazu sagen können, der halt einfach die zweite Liga kennt. Und das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt so der vom Ansatz her so der typische Absteiger-Dominanz-Auftritt, den man sich vorstellen könnte. Aber er funktioniert ja dann doch ganz gut.
Ja, liegt es vielleicht an Dimitrios Gramozis, Matthias, dass man eben gar nicht so spielt, wie der große Erstligaverein, der abgestiegen ist, sondern halt wie eine Zweitligamannschaft spielen muss, weil er halt auch die Erfahrung hat?
Ich glaube, dass Gramozis ein Trainer ist, der ein Team das spielen lässt, was es kann. Also, dass er jetzt auch keine überbauten Erwartungen an ein Team hat. Klar will er ein Team weiterentwickeln. Das hat er in Darmstadt geschafft, indem er ihn dann doch den eher destruktiveren Ansatz peu à peu ausgetrieben hat, ohne jetzt die defensive Stabilität zu verleugnen. Also, die war auch in Darmstadt unter ihm durchaus gegeben und ich glaube, im Moment, also es gab auch in Darmstadt damals ein paar Gerüchte, dass als er seinen Abgang klar war, dann nicht mehr der allergrößte Ehrgeiz am Stadt war, aber das kann auch einfach nur Gossip sein und muss nicht für wahre Münze genommen werden, aber er hat, von meinen Begriffen, in Darmstadt gute Arbeit geleistet. Es zeigt jetzt auch in Schalke, dass er die richtigen Stellschrauben findet und die jetzt nicht überdreht, sondern sorgsam justiert, so würde ich es jetzt mal von außen betrachtet bewerten. Ich glaube auch, dass Pahlson nach Schalke gegangen ist, war primär sein Verdienst. Also, die hatten sich schon zu Darmstädter Zeiten gut verstanden und das zeigt sich ja jetzt erneut, dass da sich schnell die entscheidenden Faktoren zusammengefunden haben und vielleicht noch ein Fun-Fact zu Freisel. Ich hatte mal, als er noch in Sandhausen war, vernommen, dass er wohl ein ehemaliger Skifahrer gewesen sei und habe jetzt im Vorfeld der Sendung nochmal recherchiert. Also er hat sich wohl selber mal als einer der Top 3 Junior-Skifahrer in Niederösterreich bezeichnet. Also er scheint auch da Qualitäten zu haben, nicht nur zwischen den Pfosten.
Na gut, da hat er ja also. Also er hat Erfahrung damit, wenn es steil berg abgeht und dann passt er natürlich auch zu einer Mannschaft, die abgestürzt ist wie Schalke 04.
Wobei Niederösterreich wahrscheinlich nicht so viele hohe Berge haben wird wie Tirol.
Das ist dann zwischen den Stangen muss er sich ja beim Skifahren auch sehr gut.
Gut, also das ist Schalke 04. Für die läuft es gerade sehr gut und dann haben wir über allen drohend den FC St. Pauli mit 25 Punkten nach elf Spieltagen und man schießt halt einfach sehr gerne Tore auf St. Pauli. Seit der letzten Aufnahme ist geschehen ein 3 zu 0 gegen Dynamo Dresden, ein 4 zu 2 in Heidenheim, ein 4 zu 0 gegen Hansa Rostock. Wobei, wobei, Flo, da könnte man jetzt natürlich auch ein bisschen die umgedrehte Dynamo Dresden-Diskussion führen, denn mit Rostock und Dresden sind da zwei Mannschaften mit dabei, wo die Spiele emotional sehr aufgeladen sind, die aber auch St. Pauli als etablierte Zweitlegermannschaft gewinnen muss. Wo liegt denn jetzt dann die Wahrheit in der aktuellen Dominanz bei St. Pauli? Wie gut sind die Hamburger?
Ich finde die so gut, wie die Tabelle sagt, aber mein Urteil muss ja nicht stimmen. Aber an sich finde ich schon, also ich finde die von allem dem, was man so sieht, schon am beeindruckendsten. Also da ist eine konstante offensive Produktion. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass die einfach nur, also um jetzt mal den FCN nochmal rauszunehmen, die haben am Wochenende auch vier Tore gemacht, aber ich glaube je nach Anbieter irgendwo zwischen 0,7 und 1,0 Expected Goals haben die halt vier Tore gemacht. Und wenn man sich dann mal anguckt, was St. Pauli hat, die konstant in den letzten Spielen immer auf zwei oder über zwei lagen und das eigentlich in sehr, sehr vielen der Spiele reproduzieren. Also von daher, da ist einfach sehr viel Qualität in der Offensive da. Auch da spielt man ja mit 4-4-2 mit Raute, hat da mit Thierry auch noch jemanden, der dann zusätzlich noch reingeht. Da ist einfach sehr, sehr viel offensive Qualität da und dann kommt dann eben noch dazu, mit Pacarada wahrscheinlich den besten Linksverteidiger der zweiten Liga zusätzlich noch, der auch ganz viel nach vorne anschiebt. Also es ist einfach, es macht sehr viel Spaß St. Pauli zuzuschauen und das kommt dann obendrein auch noch drauf zu den vielen Toren und zu der Dynamik. Klar sind immer, wir sind in der zweiten Liga, es gibt in jedem Spiel Momente, wo man sich denkt, naja, wenn das jetzt in die andere Richtung rutscht, dann könnte es auch anders aussehen, aber sie haben halt auch diese Konstanz-Stunt drin. Also kann mich jetzt eigentlich, ich glaube, gegen Paderborn war mal ein Spiel, das nicht so gut lief, aber ansonsten. Das ist eigentlich größtenteils richtig, richtig stark, wie die spielen und auftreten und dann halt auch durchaus auch mal durchtauschen können und relativ viel Kader-Tiefe haben und dann mit, und da blutet mir natürlich als Nürnberger jetzt das Herz, wenn man sieht, wie viele Ex-Nürnberger da spielen und das sind ja nicht nur, nicht nur Burgstaller und Ditken, wo man es weiß, sondern mit Jakov Medic und mit Nikola Vasili.
Mensch, gibt es da irgendeine Verbindung vom Club zu St. Pauli?
Ich überlege mit Andreas Bornemann als Sportvorstand oder Sportchef, ich weiß gar nicht, wie es in Hamburg heißt. Aber man merkt dann, es sind halt auch so Transfers wie eben Leute, die in Nürnberg U21 gespielt haben und die dann irgendwie über Umwege da gelandet sind. Aber Medic tut mir persönlich ganz, ganz besonders weh, weil ich begleite ja die U21 auch noch immer mit und das war wirklich einer der wenigen, wo man quasi fast mit dem ersten Ballkontakt hat. Das war gleich ein Pass aus der Tiefe in den Lauf des Angreifers, der dann das gleich vollendet hat. Also es war wirklich so mit dem ersten Moment einer, wo ich gesagt habe, der wird mal was. Und mich hat es dann auch geärgert, dass man den Weg gegangen ist, dass man ihn halt erst nach Wehen verliehen hat und dann war er ja zwei Jahre verliehen und Wehen hat dann irgendwann die Kaufoptionen gezogen und letztes Jahr war er ja dann irgendwie teilweise Zehner und und Stürmer bei Wehen, weil die so viele Ausfälle glaube ich hatten, dass er dann auch da gespielt hat und selbst das hat er gut gemacht. Also das ist denke ich schon so ein Schlüsseltransfer und Wasili ist auch ein sehr, sehr solider Torwart, der dann über sehr viele Umwege, ja der kam ja aus der Ukraine, dann bei St. Pauli gelandet ist. Aber da ist, da ist viel gut beim Einkaufen passiert. Also Andreas Bornemann hat halt seine Verbindungen spielen lassen. Er ist jetzt auch nicht derjenige, der wahnsinnig viel, also im Gegensatz zum Beispiel zu Darmstadt, ja jetzt viel auf Datenscouting und so weiter setzt. Also das ist ja ein Anse- oder auch Dieter Hecking macht das nicht. Also das ist ja eher noch so Netzwerken und wir schauen, wen wir kennen. Aber das hat er eben sehr, sehr gut gemacht.
Da war jetzt sehr viel Lob mit dabei. Matthias, was willst du ergänzen?
Also gefällt mir auch sehr gut. Gerade das Spiel haben wir ja noch vom Wochenende vor Augen, das 4-0 gegen Rostock. Das war ja phasenweise in den Rausch gespielt. Also wirklich Hut ab. Da geht einiges auf der Zeit. Thierry auch hervorragend. Spielt jetzt mittlerweile auch in der garnerischen Nationalmannschaft. Mit Burgstaller eine gute Kombi vorne drin. Mit Marcel Hartl haben sie sich jetzt fast noch die garantierte Aufstiegspersonalie geholt, der zuletzt mit Bielfeld und Union hochgegangen ist. Den muss man auch erst mal aneinander ziehen. Wenn wir uns aber zurück erinnern, also zu Beginn des Jahres, wir hatten ja eigentlich keine Winterpause durch die Corona-bedingte Späteansetzung der Saison. Da war St. Pauli, ich habe noch mal nachgeschaut, mit 9 Punkten auf Rang 17 und seither haben sie 64 Punkte geholt. Das ist schon wirklich ein unfassbarer Lauf, ohne dass man jetzt den Coach ausgetauscht hätte, Timo Schulz, ist jetzt in seine 2. Saison gegangen und scheint ja, warum auch immer, einen wahnsinnigen Turnaround herbeigeführt zu haben. Und das nötigt mir auch gehörigen Respekt ab. Also, wenn man auch betrachtet, dass so ein Personal wie Christoffer Abeworr seit einem Jahr schon verletzt ist und es fällt gar nicht auf, und er war ja schon einer der prägnanteren Innenverteidiger der 2. Liga. Auch das zeigt, dass St. Pauli sich enorm gefestigt und weiterentwickelt hat in den letzten Monaten. Das ist kein laues Lüftchen, das ist schon mit Substanz.
Und ja, auch die Abgänge gut kompensiert. Oma Mamouche ist ja da. Derjenige, den man jetzt auch in der 1. Liga sehen kann. Salazar zu Frankfurt und noch so manch anderer. Das interessante bei Timo Schulz, dadurch, dass es diese wunderbare Podcast-Dokumentation Being Timo Schulz von Millenton gibt, kann man ja ganz gut nachvollziehen, wie er auch diese turbulente letzte Saison gesehen hat, weil die haben über 20 Telefonate mit ihm geführt und daraus dann eben einen die Saison begleitenden, im Rückblick begleitenden Podcast gemacht. Das Interessante ist, alles, was er da gesagt hat, das scheint auch jetzt genau so zu kommen. Also er hat mit ihnen darüber gesprochen, wann er auf Defensive umgestellt hat. Er hat mit ihnen über Raute und Spielauslösung gesprochen und hat mit ihnen auch darüber gesprochen, wo es jetzt noch weitergehen muss, wo man besser werden muss. Nicht nur im Umschaltverhalten, sondern eben auch aus dem Ballbesitzer Rauslösung finden, eben diese Raute noch ein bisschen kreativer ausspielen. Und all die Dinge sind jetzt einfach passiert. Und das, obwohl eben wichtige Spieler gegangen sind, ist ja schön, wenn es auch mal so kommt, wenn das, was Trainer planen, doch auch mal umgesetzt wird. So grüßt dann der FC St. Pauli von der Tabellenspitze und ihm geht es sehr gut da oben. Ihr zwei, ich danke euch sehr. Das war eine lange, aber ich finde sehr interessante Aufnahme und das liegt ausschließlich an euch beiden. Ich bin sehr froh, dass ich euch mal wieder im Rasenfunk mit dabei hatte. Ganz herzlichen Dank an Florian Zenger. Folgt ihm auf Twitter, da ist er der atflo-zenger und ihr könnt natürlich ihn auch in diversen Publikationen verfolgen bei der Nürnberger Zeitung und den Nürnberger Nachrichten und bei Club Fans United und im KDEP Podcast. Flo, vielen Dank, dass du neben deinen ganzen 1000 Projekten zusätzlich zu deinem Lehrer-Job auch noch hier im Rasenfunk warst. Mir ebenso. Und ganz herzlichen Dank auch an Matthias Kneifl vom Hoch und Weit Podcast, der sich vielleicht jetzt umbenennen muss. Das habe ich mir vorhin gedacht, als du gesagt hast, ich spiele gar nicht mehr Hoch und Weit. Da dachte ich mir, was? Das ist ja Etikettenschwindel.
Wir bleiben uns treu. Zumindest vom Namen her.
Immerhin der Kickschuh-Blog kann noch so weiter so heißen, das stimmt. Als AtKickschuh-Blog kann man dir auch auf Twitter folgen, natürlich auch dem Podcast Hoch und Weit. Danke dir, Matthias, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Recht herzlichen Dank.
Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist werbepayable und sponsorunfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure Spenden. Wie ihr uns unterstützt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclubund nicht nur wir profitieren davon, sondern auch unsere Gäste, die ein kleines Honorar bekommen für ihre Auftritte hier. In diesem Sinne, bitte unterstützt uns. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. Und dann hören wir uns wieder in der nächsten Woche in der Schlusskonferenz und natürlich auch hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Bis dahin macht's gut.